bear in mind once again that whatever
Hank says goes he is an impartial third
party on the one hand this copier is
very old you should see some of the new
copy as they have you would not believe
what they do so The copier well let me
finish all right yes now the chairs
the chairs are very weak very weak
chairs I could not sit all day in this
chair
well what should I do
let me see The copier again all right
get out get out
okay so now you're sure that everything
is okay you know down there you're
perfectly healthy
that man has the largest penis I have
ever seen
actually don't even know if he has mops
forgot to look
I was distracted
by the largest penis I have ever seen
oh boy NYPD sir have you seen anything
unusual today oh no
this was nice thank you wait
what is this music
oh this is from my country near krakato
govia do you like it I weirdly do
[Applause]
[Music]
you see Amy fun thing about working
cases you meet people from all over the
world
this song is a celebration song from
when a dog loses his virginity look who
checks that
now
get down get dunk it down touch the
ground
get out
they calm down do the same nobody gets
hurt this is what I trained once you're
almost there killing somebody every
minute unless
unless you agree to marry me Cheyenne
hit it hey what the oh
also Daryl FYI I already told this to
Andy but uh you should probably know I
technically don't have a hearing problem
it's just when there's a lot of noises
please
thank you
you have no business education you are
going to take classes under D'Angelo
what happened to that he died he didn't
die his brain died and my brain is still
very much alive and I'd be happy to give
you business classes how come you
haven't asked me about it what would
what was the last
I'm having no no part of this has
anything to do with you
councilman I'd like to talk to you about
the fun in the sun bill and I don't mean
to rush you but the vote is in an hour
when I'm done eating we'll talk I've
eaten the same lunch for 58 years Caesar
salad extra dressing extra croutons and
extra anchovies
hmm councilman Milton was first elected
as a city councilor in 1948 as a member
of the dixiecrat party their platform
deintegrate baseball the secret is
didn't address try it it's an
aphrodisiac
you too my strange foreign friend no
thank you Tom eats some I'm not eating
racist salad the more we eat the faster
we talk thank you
mmm
you can really taste the ignorance it's
pronounced anchovies we're going to
kidnap a cop but not just any cop it
needs to be someone so high ranking that
it sends shockwaves through the system
but not important enough that their
absence negatively impacts the NYPD in
any way
what are you guys thinking we're clearly
all looking at you oh God am I in charge
of the meeting dismissed dismissed no
you're getting kidnapped CJ Amy Charles
and I will be the kidnappers Captain
Holt is the driver here's how it'll go
down approaching the target all right
let's do this mask song actually scratch
that we're not going to use ski masks
we'll use cool rubber masks oh we should
be the ladies of the First Wives Club I
call Keaton we're not going to do First
Wives Club masks just because you can't
be Keaton grow up Jake no because they
don't exist and also yeah Keaton is
clearly the coolest one and I don't
think it's really fair that you just
called her but forget it we'll wear
scary gorilla masks approaching the
target okay let's do this Mass son but
CJ goes to get his morning coffee we
will arrive and grab him he will pretend
to struggle just enough to attract
attention
we write this down so I remember my
lines I can see that you already have
the word milk written on your hand I
know where this is going Milk Milk hi
guys uh does everyone know my boyfriend
Bob Vance Kevin Malone Bob Vance Vance
Refrigeration Stanley Hudson Bob Vance
Vance Refrigeration Brian Howard Bob
Vance Vance Refrigeration
for line and work you in Bob
this is Dr Leos pachiman hi I work with
Tracy Jordan and I think he's having a
reaction to some of the medication you
put him on uh I was afraid this might
happen you know he's on so many
different neuroleptics and tricyclics
that there's no telling how they'll mix
but what can you do medicine's not a
science well what exactly are you
treating him for ah there's not really a
name for what Tracy has basically it's
erratic Tendencies and delusions brought
on by excessive notoriety and certainly
not helped by my wildly experimental
treatments
boy I'm being awfully open with you miss
I should not have taken those blue
things financial analysis automated
general ledger accounting systems audit
management you've done everything well
they call me the Swiss Army accountant
they'll call me that you should well
look I think you'd be a great addition
would you be willing to come back to
meet the division head yes absolutely
we'll set that up okay great thank you
well uh
calculator
we do not get a lot of humor here and
when we do it's wonderful oh Tad come in
here
I'm gonna say 30. ah 40. it's like
repellent which clearly need reduces the
effectiveness of SPF good point but I
thought of that already combination SPF
repellent whoa oh man of course you
think the EPA would ever allow that much
Deet
Ralph is my best friend we met in a shoe
store I heard him asking for a shoe that
could increase his speed and not leave
any tracks
[Applause]
now it's seven six or is that too much
accounting for you is a mechanic
question for you what does one fiancee
plus one lover equal
answer one okay knock it off Ralph
what she's sitting there please I'm
asking nicely you don't mean that leave
it alone
go you got it we need to keep the line
moving we have a lot of hungry angry
people out there oh you can just say
hangry now it's a new word my friend's
cousin made it up
I'll take rolls veggies and condiments
you start slicing the meat slicing the
meat
oh sweet always wanted to work this bad
boy not totally sure how it works just
um load the meat and then slice the meat
definitely
um a quick study so oh I cut myself
already oh maybe I should do
Marcus that looks really bad just a Nick
it looks worse than it is kind of stings
a little
[Applause]
Marcus
is that your thumb
ah
I don't know you don't know
why don't you check I don't wanna Marcus
check I don't want to see if your thumb
is on your hands
all right